while the class rooms were empty this
Easter the corridors quiet in a few
schools the canteens were open meeting
demand in North air sure they know they
have families that really struggle in
the holidays the teachers have become
used to spotting the signs more
expensive during the whole of these they
get to wait to D average I activate
before maybe stuff for lunch today
really coming up with really John I know
there was nothing like this when I with
this it does benefit offense as well
because it button key comment in that
environment you see on our dealer traces
of course this is what the holidays
should be about the meals that come out
of the school canteens also end up at
this community center in Kilwinning
helping kids like Daryl tell me about
how different you feel once you've had a
good meal
how do you feel after you've had a good
lunch it's a great word buff you
energize kids don't always get that the
mule that they need younger D through
fourth up its money stay here I'm Sami
to see these stuff let me do you like
new and age and things didn't catch that
you know and get I got a fitter and
nowhere it's a bit it's it's different
I'm sure that I'm sure that the Robbie
feel barely the quaint hard feel that
create their acts this isn't just
confined to the big cities all kinds of
children from all kinds of backgrounds
experience holy hunger
for all kinds of reasons the report
concludes crucially that it is a
solvable problem just as they prove here
every holiday the all party group on
hunger in Westminster say this is an
evil in our midst and it can be put
right with money from the sugary drinks
tax overall it would take forty one and
a half million pounds to solve the group
suggests giving a hundred thousand
pounds to each local authority who would
then have a duty to help something they
already do in North air show they can
perform better at school they can get
better jobs that can go to further
education whilst it's costing us at the
front end almost here it will be wider
benefits that will easily outweigh the
70,000 pounds or so it cost alia to
provide this scheme not all the young
people here live in poverty but most are
aware of it some people take things for
granted of what the law
[Music]
recognising that is key to solving it I
think it's something that a lot of
people maybe shun maybe the white you
see it there what didn't believe it that
I was kids in this country who need to
hold me alive really and I believe that
the the or wheel you know we don't think
that excess is s oblivia it is a growing
problem more families are asking for
help but there is still no UK strategy
to deal with it and still children are
going hungry
Tom Parmenter Sky News North Asia